uh today the president spoke with new
york city mayor eric adams to express
his heartfelt condolences and offer his
support following yesterday's
devastating fire at a bronx apartment
building which took the lives of at
least 19 people in the wake of this
terrible tragedy the president wanted to
reach out to offer comfort and also
offer support in case there's anything
the mayor needs our hearts go out to
everyone who is impacted and we are
very appreciative of the heroic work of
the first responders who are on the
scene so quickly i know some of you have
asked about assistance i'm not aware of
any requests for federal assistance but
of course we will let you know if
there's anything to share and we will
remain in close contact with uh leaders
there as well with that zeke why don't
you kick us
off uh
in geneva right now um has the president
been briefed on the first round of
negotiations over the past couple of
days and uh
what is the current us government
assessment of russian intentions when it
comes to eastern ukraine
well the president meets as you know
regularly with his national security
team uh members of his national security
team as he did uh this morning i don't
mean a formal nsc meeting i mean uh the
regular pdb meeting where he is uh
receives regular updates as you know
those talks just uh ended late this
morning i think you probably have all
seen deputy secretary of state wendy
sherman did a briefing following uh the
conclusion of those as well uh i would
just reiterate some of the points that
she made of course uh that um these
talks uh were frank uh that uh and
forthright um and there was a discussion
from the united from the u.s side of
what what our expectations are in a
reiteration of what you've heard the
president say and what you've heard many
officials from
the united states say which is that
there are two paths for russia to take
at this point for president putin to
take he can take the path to diplomacy
there's two more rounds of talks this
week we've seen them as a package of
three which i think they also reiterated
from their side or there's a path of
escalation we are certainly hopeful that
the path to diplomacy is the path
that they will take there are of course
a range of topics discussed during that
meeting including a reiteration of what
is at stake
should they decide to move forward and
invade ukraine in terms of an assessment
of where they stand
i would really leave that to the
russians to articulate we can't give an
assessment of that from here and deputy
secretary sherman did not as well what
would it look like for the russians to
choose the diplomatic path is that just
does that mean they have to withdraw
some of their forward deployed forces on
the board with ukraine in order to have
that more sustained engagement or
they're just not not invading further
would keep the diplomatic
conversation alive well zeke there are a
hundred thousand troops at the border
now obviously returning those troops to
the barracks returning troops to the
barracks uh conveying to us their
intention of doing that uh is certainly
would be easy ways to show de-escalation
as i noted a little bit earlier we see
this as a path as a as a set of three
rounds of conversations that will occur
uh this week
as you've heard many of our national
security officials state but i will
reiterate from here uh no talks without
about europe without europe no talks
without you about ukraine without
ukraine and that is certainly our
mentality so we are moving forward with
the other two rounds of talks and
discussions here but absolutely the
aggressive action the bellicose rhetoric
came from the russians so they have the
ability and the power to de-escalate
the president's trip tomorrow atlanta um
craig got special in the complaint on
friday uh but a number of advocates
for voting rights and other issues down
there said the president should not come
down unless he has a plan to actually
pass
a
voting rights legislation what is the
president's plan to pass that or is he
going down there without without a plan
well his plan is to sign voting rights
legislation into law that requires the
majority of senators to support it uh
even if there are changes to uh the the
uh the senate rules which is something
the president has expressed an openness
to
but let me give you a little bit of a
preview of what people can expect
to hear from him tomorrow
i would just note that the backdrop of
where he's going is vitally important
here as we were planning the trip in a
it's in a place with profound civil
rights history the atlanta university
center consortium on the grounds of
clark atlanta university and morehouse
college in atlanta uh the president will
forcefully advocate for protecting the
most bedrock american rights the right
to vote and have your voice counted in a
free fair and secure election that is
not
tainted tainted by partisan manipulation
he'll make clear in the former district
of the late congressman john lewis that
the only way to do that are for the
senate to pass the freedom to vote act
and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act he will follow his
remarks from last week on the
anniversary of january 6 where he did
touch on voting rights and that
fundamental
importance of protecting that right
when an unprecedented insurrection
sought to violently violently overturn
the outcome of what the trump
administration's top election security
officials confirmed was the most secure
election in history by saying that he
will stand in the breach and keep
fighting for the soul of america and
i'll also describe this as one of the
rare moments in a country's history when
time stops and the essential is
immediately ripped away from the trivial
and that we have to ensure january 6th
doesn't mark the end of democracy but
the beginning of a renaissance for our
democracy where we stand up for the
right to vote and have that vote counted
fairly uh not undermined bipartisans
afraid of who you voted for or try to
reserve verse and outcome i would also
note one other piece i think you can
you'll hear more from him on tomorrow is
he's quite focused on uh how
ensuring the american people understand
what is at stake here uh sometimes we
all are uh
we all shorthand uh legislation or
shorthand uh what we're talking about
and protecting the fundamental right to
vote means he's going to also talk about
uh what the changes have meant in states
like georgia across the country uh what
uh what is at stake for for uh voters in
georgia and other states across the
country and and why this is so
imperative that move forward
lastly senator schumer said in a
deadline of a week from now from the
center pass this legislation or change
senate rules the president optimistic
that that could happen on that time
frame or does he think that that is
maybe too ambitious well he's going to
continue to work in lockstep with leader
schumer on
moving this vote forward but
beyond that we're taking it day by day
to press for the vote to happen and to
be successful good
um just following up on some of those
questions so on atlanta will stacy
abrams be joining the president during
any of these
remarks andre i know we'll have a list
uh there will be a number of elected
officials joining us uh traveling and
also there i think we're still
finalizing that list and we will venture
to get you that as soon as possible okay
and then uh just our favorite topic is
the fed nominations that we were
expecting in december are you can you
give us any kind of guidance on when we
could expect those
we we hope to have more specific than
soon i i wish i had something more
specific to deliver to you today but i
can just continue to reiterate we the
president looks forward to announcing
those soon okay and then uh just on the
fed issue uh elizabeth warren has spoken
out about reports uh that indicate that
uh governor clarida
made some purchases and sales and is
calling for greater transparency is this
an issue that the president is engaged
on and
do you think it's time for a kind of a
more serious look at what is you know
what the rules are that govern the
federal reserve's actions and whether
it's topic
well the we and the president deeply
respect the independence of the federal
reserve and we're not going to comment
on uh recent developments but i can say
uh broadly speaking the president
believes that all government agencies
and officials including the federal
reserve including independent agencies
should be held to the highest ethical
standards including the avoidance of any
suggestions of conflict conflicts of
interest of interest
the fed is obviously an independent
agency as i've stated a few times it has
its own ethics rules and requirements
including new rules issued in october to
address uh conflicts and so we defer to
that agency about any specific
follow-ups
um and just to follow up on on
the issue
on that issue with the fed
so
i understand it's an independent agency
but you know if an independent agency is
if officials at an independent agency
are not following the rules to the
letter or if those rules don't seem like
they're covering the whole thing is it
time to take
a closer look even beyond what happened
in october well again andrea i think the
president respects the independence of
the federal reserve i just noted that
they have their own ethics rules and
requirements they put new rules in place
in october i point you to them but the
president's expectation that all
government agencies and officials
including independent agencies are held
to a high standard uh high ethical uh
with high ethical standards uh avoiding
conflict of interest uh speaks for
itself
so we know that the um
we know that the
rapid test
you know contracts have gone out but
they've gone to companies that basically
procure materials as opposed to
um
uh companies that are manufacturing the
tests are you satisfied that there's
adequate
testing of you know manufacturing
capability in place and going to procure
the tests well let me give you a little
bit of an update on kind of a couple of
timelines or updates on timelines i
should say on where things stand um
we're working closely with manufacturing
distributors to understand
uh what they can ship and by when as
well as actively working through the
timelines for distribution as you kind
of touched on there in your question
there are several components of this so
we want to ensure that there's not only
that physical test but the ability to
distribute them
which is what we're working through
right now
we expect
that the contracts are structured in a
way to require that significant amounts
are delivered on an aggressive timeline
the first of which should be arriving
early next week we expect to have all
contracts awarded over the next two
weeks and then americans will begin
being able to order these tests online
later this month we also expect to have
details on the website as well as a
hotline later this week so these are all
components that we're working through
and working to expedite as quickly as
possible
hospitalizations which are now at a
record level um are you is there
anything that the federal government can
do to
augment the capacity of hospitals which
are now having to cancel selective
surgeries i think in something like more
than half of u.s states
um is that something where dod could
come in with mobile field hospitals
perhaps to just offer additional
capacity well we actually have uh
deployed a number of resources from uh
to surge resources over the course of
the last several months we will continue
to do that and we're working with local
health authorities
state leaders local leaders to determine
where there are the greatest needs but
we have deployed a range of uh of
resources uh many of them through fema
uh to ensure that local communities who
have high higher surges or different
needs in different ways i should say i
have resources from the federal
government
good
on the kind of nascent bipartisan talks
related to kind of more scaled back
targeted approach on uh the electoral
count act uh the mr bates was quite
definitive uh that that wasn't really an
option the white house was pursuing
right now it certainly was no substitute
i think to use uh his words as part of
the reason for being so definitive on
that is that you don't want an off ramp
for
two democratic senators in particular to
point to instead of considering that
rules change in a sense i've always
known my colleague mr bates to be
definitive i don't know if you all
experienced that as well but um i think
what
what our position is from here and what
the position of many advocates for
voting rights and many democrats on the
hill is is that it is not a substitute
and we should not treat it like a
substitute because the two bills that
the president will talk about tomorrow
uh have um essential components of them
that will protect people's fundamental
rights expand access ensure that people
know that when they vote it will count
and not be overturned and
we want to be very clear with the public
that it is not a replacement or a
minority leader mitch mcconnell has
declared war on this effort over the
course of the last several weeks on the
senate floor his office put out a
lengthy memo last night that said in
part democrats will try to use
hysteria
to break the senate and silence millions
of americans voices so they can take
over elections um the president's been a
little sharper towards republicans you
have a response to that memo
i
it is pretty ironic if if making it more
difficult to vote is not silencing the
voices of people words that senator
mcconnell used i don't know what is
i also think it's important to note here
if you look back at
leader mcconnell's record from the past
he has a pretty strong record of
supporting voting rights um and what has
changed that's a question for him less
for us but i will i will give you a few
examples 2004 leonard mcconnell i cannot
think of any reason why anyone on either
side of the aisle would oppose the
protection of the franchise of all
americans 2006 the voting rights act of
1965 represents one of this country's
greatest steps forward obviously arise
today in support of its reauthorization
again 2006
he wrote in his memoir that he was
overwhelmed to witness such a moment in
history when the voting rights act
passed in 1965.
so i use those examples to remind people
that this should not be a partisan issue
protecting people's fundamental voting
rights uh that people uh should be
protecting them and standing up for
americans of all political stripes that
is what we are working to do and what
we're talking about here is uh fighting
against the big lie that was perpetuated
after january 6th
in around january 6 i should say by many
far too many republicans in congress
and it has resulted in states across the
country putting in place more
laws that are making it more difficult
to people to exercise their rights we
don't think that is right we don't think
that is a political issue it is a
fundamental right in this country and it
should be
uh one more just unfold that better just
i have to ask about that
um
look i understand you guys can walk and
shoot gum at the same time
and talking to democrats in both
chambers uh some over here as well
there's just not a lot of sets that the
conversations you guys have said are
ongoing right now are going at a pretty
significant clip or are substantive at
this point so where are you guys and
what are the next tests here
well um
our conversations are continuing behind
the scenes at a staff level um and i can
assure you that and assure the american
people
that the president is going to continue
to press to get uh buildback better done
to ensure that we are lowering costs for
americans across the country most
importantly to ensure we are lowering
costs for americans across the country
on child care on elder care on health
care addressing the climate crisis we
know that we were we need 50 votes in
order to get that legislation done and
we need to figure out what that looks
like to get that legislation done but
those conversations are happening behind
the scenes
and the president remains absolutely
committed to uh getting uh lowering
costs for the american people
on voting rights when you do hear the
criticism from some advocates about
don't come without the plan or others
who say president has not been
personally enough involved
as he heads to this does he feel he has
the political influence
to be the tipping point
this week
well kelly it's a hard question to
answer because really what we're talking
about is whether we can get enough votes
in congress to get this done
and that's why i think it's important to
note that the president will talk about
this
as a fundamental right for all americans
something that there has been a history
of supporting from both sides of the
aisle
something that the public should expect
and demand from their elected officials
to support
i think we would dispute the notion that
the president hasn't been active or
vocal he's given a range of speeches
he's advocated for voting rights to pass
he said it is a fundamental priority for
his presidency and he has agreed with
his vice president that she would lead
this effort we understand the
frustration by many advocates that this
is not passed into law yet he would love
to have signed this into law himself but
tomorrow is an opportunity to speak
about what the path forward looks like
to advocate for uh for this moving
forward in the senate can you speak to
the role of the vice president tomorrow
and what she will be talking about and
how that relates to the president's
message
absolutely the the vice president of
course uh has an important role to play
here as the person who is leading this
effort and will continue to lead this
effort from the administration she has
worked to date to
help build a groundswell of support
something that many grassroots advocates
have been working on for many years now
but she has met with a number of these
advocates she has engaged and she's
going to continue to
speak about voting rights across the
country uh in terms of the preview of
her remarks uh we're not quite there yet
uh maybe we'll have some more to say
about hers and the presidents later this
evening as the president has heard
feedback from geneva on the state of uh
the negotiations or conversations there
is he giving any uh sort of incremental
instructions to wendy sherman and the
team about things he would like
introduced into the talks or is he
leaving
that to be an on the ground sort of
discussion for those who are in the room
and handling it
physically there
well he is in regular touch uh with
members of his national security team
and they are in touch with team members
on the ground uh so i would say we are
looking again at this week as a set of
conversations and we will see and be
able to assess where things stand uh
better uh at the end of that i will note
a couple of things um
that uh
as you're looking at this um
we um we we we are preparing ourselves
for the possibility and likelihood no
one should be surprised i should say
if russia spreads disinformation about
commitments that have not been made or
if it goes even further and instigates
something as a pretext for further
destabilizing activity and so we would
continue to urge everyone not to fall
for any attempts to push in
disinformation out there but for the
president the most important thing to
convey and that he's conveying to his
team is that no talks uh without no
talks about europe without europe no
talks about ukraine without ukraine uh
we had these discussions with the
russians today there are important uh
conversations that will be happening on
the 12th in brussels and the 13th
in vienna and this is just one part
of a three-set series of discussions
happening this week go ahead oh sorry
peter i'll come back to you i'm sorry go
ahead thank you very much i can ask you
for the latest on the chicago schools
closure dispute uh the governor
announced over the weekend the
availability of tests he previously
thought the administration's helping
procuring tests can you say whether the
350 000 they procured involved federal
involvement at all and whether those
talks are ongoing and broadly do you
have any message to both the chicago
teachers union and the mayor of chicago
on what you hope to see there in the
coming days this of course is the fourth
day in a row
well
i would say first that we are in regular
touch with the governor and his team and
the mayor as well so we can continue to
convey uh have those conversations
behind the scenes we have been very
clear publicly and privately that we
want to see schools open uh that the
president fought for
additional assistance in the american
rescue plan 130 billion dollars
including 5 billion dollars that went to
illinois 10 billion dollars that went to
testing across the country to ensure we
were prepared and had resources needed
uh to address whatever may come up in
the pandemic but we are having these
conversations we are in regular touch
with them uh both the mayor and the
governor and we'll continue to see how
we can assist from here is a prominent
member of the president's party has he
spoken to her directly i mean does he
feel the need to intervene here it seems
like sort of an exceptional case in
chicago when so many other cities are
reopening the
[ __ ] offend in some ways well i'm not
gonna obviously speak for the mayor but
i think the mayor has also conveyed what
her view is here as well uh the
president's view is to uh that schools
should be open across the country and
more than 95 percent are across the
country that the mental health impacts
on kids of not having schools open is is
very harsh and hard and he does not want
to see schools closed across the country
so that there's no secret about that
that continues to be what he states
that's why he fought for funding and we
will continue to be in touch with local
leaders in chicago to work to get their
schools open jake sullivan had a
statement over the weekend with regards
to iran and sanctions that alluded to
threats against american
officials should we interpret from that
the us's intelligence have there been
threats in particular against trump
officials who are evolved involved in
the solemn money strike
well i'm not going to get into
intelligence here from the podium but
we've certainly seen concerning public
rhetoric from iranian officials about
individuals from previous
administrations even before sanctions
from this weekend
and that's unacceptable as
the national security adviser jake
sullivan said in his statement over the
weekend that you just referenced
as americans we have our disagreements
on politics on iran policy and other
issues of course but we are united in
our resolve against threats and
provocations we're united in the defense
of our people and we're going to protect
and defend our own people uh but i'm not
going to get into more specifics
obviously
they announced say the sanctioning of
more than 50 individuals and have made
public comments in addition that are
certainly available to anyone oh good
sorry for you go in you're finding your
finances
you open the door to maybe some sort of
virus aid
measure coming through uh do you have
any new update on whether the white
house is involved in any talks towards
that for instance restaurant forces had
some traction in the senate about a
potential pop-up of that fund
well we we certainly agree with speaker
pelosi on a lot of things but on the
fact that um on what she said this
weekend which is that we're not going to
let a lack of resources get in the way
of fighting the pandemic we have been in
constant conversation with leaders and
with uh the hill and members about what
may be needed uh whether that's more to
address covid or small businesses and
help keep them afloat i don't have
anything specific at this point in time
but we're going to continue to assess uh
what the needs are and stay in close
touch with them about that go ahead
thank you jen i was home all last week
isolated welcome back thank you i was
isolating with covid after a positive
test like a lot of people watching
and a lot of time in front of the tv i
heard the president say did you watch
fox gold time or other things i have
exhausted the full catalog of guy fieri
content oh okay
and obviously a lot of [ __ ] but i i
heard the president say
google coped test near me so
somebody isolating with kovid i did that
and the appointment's everywhere were
completely jammed so why is it that you
guys were so unprepared
for the
need for testing after the holidays
well peter i'm happy to see you back and
well um i would second say that there
has been a massive surge in cases as you
know and we're a part of in dc and new
york and there's been an unprecedented
in other parts of the country as well
there's been an unprecedented demand for
tests so what we have done over the
course of the last few weeks even before
that is the president quadrupled our
testing capacity since the summer we
opened 20 000 sites across the country
and we have also opened additional
federal sites including one in dc only
recently he's also provided we've also
in the process of sending 50 million
tests out to community health centers
and rural health centers and now we've
just we're in the process of finalizing
contracts for 500 million tests but what
can i make one more point and then you
can go next i would just note where we
have come from if you look to a year ago
there were no tests or maybe one
depending on the timeline that was
available on the market now we have nine
if you look to about a year ago there
was about 900 000 or maybe slightly
higher tests that were being issued
every day now we're about 10 or 11
million 300 million tests are done in
this country every month so there's
enormous progress being made but we
needed to make sure the market was
growing that's what we've been working
on and increase our access to supply and
that's what we've been doing the tests
you're talking about require people to
go somewhere and either make an
appointment or wait in line the cdc's
guidance is if you think you have code
you're supposed to stay home you guys
said you were going to mail free tests
to people that need them the president's
there on television talking about a
winter of severe illness and death while
he's saying that publicly why weren't
you guys doing more to prepare
for the winter well peter everyone
decides where they're going to go get a
test and
we we make a range of options available
you can also purchase
today we'll have more details on how 150
million americans who have health
insurance can get reimbursed for tests
we'll have more details on that later
the 500 million tests i noted and i'll
give you a little bit of an update on
the timeline we'll have more on the
website later this week so our our steps
and our process from the beginning has
been expanding access to free tests to
make it easy and more accessible for
americans and we're continuing to build
on what we've done today the president
talked about a winter of severe illness
and death at the rate you guys are going
these tests are not going to be
available until spring so will you admit
that these free tests you guys promised
are not going to be ready until after
the omicron surge i think i gave an
update earlier that we'll have to start
to have tests out the door in the coming
weeks very soon and again that's not the
only place people can get tests
there are a range of ways people can get
tests online again you'll know more
about how you can be reimbursed for
those tests from here
go to different sites there are federal
sites opening up all around the country
we understand that you guys plan to rely
on a postal service to send out these
free tests whenever they're ready but
the postal service says they're going to
have a staffing shortage
because of your vaccine mandate so would
you pull back on the vaccine mandate if
it meant getting people these free tests
sooner the postal service also delivered
98 99 of packages on time in advance of
christmas and they also their leaders
have also said they're eager to take on
this challenge so we welcome that and
we're looking forward to working with
them to get these tests out to the
public
i understand that the science says that
vaccines prevent death
but
i'm triple backs still got coveted
you're triple backs still got coven why
is the president still referring to this
as a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
well i i think peter there's a
significant difference between and you
just you just experienced this and not
to expose your public health experience
but i can speak to mine as well i had
been triple vaxxed i had minor symptoms
there is a huge difference between that
and being unvaccinated you are 17 times
more likely to go to the hospital if
you're not vaccinated 20 times more
likely to die and those are significant
serious statistics so yes the impact uh
for people who are unvaccinated is far
more dire than those who are vaccinated
will the president update his languages
sometime to be more reflective of the
fact that people who are triple
vaccinated
are catching and spreading colvin i
think people president has said as have
we a number of times that there will be
breakthrough cases there will be people
who get covid uh here uh at different
media organizations at companies around
the world around the country uh who have
been vaccinated but there is a
significant difference between being
hospitalized or dying and
being vaccinated with more mild symptoms
and the last one you guys have been very
aggressive countering covet
misinformation so what do you guys think
about cove and misinformation coming
from the supreme court
and sonia sotomayor's false claim that
over a hundred thousand children are in
serious condition many on ventilators
well i'm not going to speak to supreme
court arguments or statements made in
those arguments
but i will tell you that what is at
stake here is our effort to protect
health workers and most importantly
protect patients with the cms role and
also to make workplaces safer with the
osha rule which we have confidence in
our legal argument for so i will leave
it to them to decide but that's what's
being argued now go
getting ahead of the president before a
major speech is one of your favorite
things to do that being said i'm in the
trends question anyway you mentioned
that over the past year president biden
has expressed more openness about taking
a look at filibuster rules especially
when it comes to voting rights is that a
topic you expect him to directly address
tomorrow and given to yes
is there an announcement in terms of
whether he'll be more forceful or
whether he'll have any any specific
thing to say other than i'm open to the
idea uh you know the president has
spoken to this issue a number of times
as i've said before including as
recently as december where he said that
if that is how we get this done i'm open
to that uh but again he's working on his
speech and uh you'll have to tune in
tomorrow and see what he has to say has
he had any specific conversations with
senators about this legislation about a
rules change in the past couple of weeks
we're in regular touch uh at a range of
levels with senators i'm not going to
detail those further last question any
response to a recent statement from
senator cinema's office indicating she
would not be in favor of changing the
rules and dealing with these two pieces
of legislation
uh look i think that everyone is going
to have to take a hard look at where
they want to be
at this moment in history as we're
looking at efforts across the country to
to prevent people from being able to
exercise their fundamental rights go
ahead
in previewing the president's speech
earlier today you said that he will
forcefully advocate for the voting
rights
last week's speech on january 6 the
president's speech then was was viewed
as as pointed and forceful in terms of
the tone of tomorrow's speech should we
expect something along those lines
well i would say that um the president
will certainly uh be clear about what is
at stake here and how important it is to
protect people's fundamental rights
across the country he felt that uh
speaking to this uh warranted a moment
where he was going to give a full speech
on it that's exactly why he's going to
georgia a place with enormous history on
civil rights issue unfortunately
enormous recent history on efforts to
suppress the vote uh so that is why he's
going uh there but january 6th it's all
connected in his view was certainly a
day where he needed to speak very
clearly about the role of his
predecessor and just put on koben can
you expand just a little bit about on
what the president said last friday when
he was asked about controlling kobit
when he mentioned the new normal was he
moving away
from his campaign pledge of shutting
down the virus or or changing the
messaging at all about about covet 19.
what he's referring to is the fact that
we have uh now we're in a different
place than we were a year ago more than
200 million americans are vaccinated
more than 71 percent are fully
vaccinated uh more than 80 or a little
higher than that have had a first dose
we have a range of tools at our disposal
including antivirals and other
treatments
so we're going to continue to expand
that but we are in a different place
than we were a year ago go ahead does
the president feel that forceful speech
that he gave last week does that raise
the bar for for getting something done
he's been talking about this for months
he had a speech in july and philadelphia
nothing's happened
as he basically raised expectations here
about giving good speeches or
voting reform but i think he believes
the stake should be raised he wouldn't
be going to georgia uh tomorrow a place
where there is enormous history of uh
from of civil rights leaders of his of
his friend john lewis uh advocating for
uh fundamental rights including voting
rights if he wasn't uh ready and
prepared to elevate this issue and
continue to fight for it
the administration has said that schools
have the resources uh to remain open uh
yet we're seeing closures including
chicago um
there's still a lot of
teachers staying away they're doing
illness or fears
other school personnel so what is the
white house prepared to do
in the event of other school closures
due to lack personnel
well i think it's important to note that
more than 95 percent of schools across
the country are open and in part because
of the resources that they were able to
receive from the american rescue plan it
enabled them to hire more bus drivers
maybe hire more teachers uh put in place
additional mitigation measures many
many uh secured con testing contracts to
ensure that there could be regular
testing at their schools there are some
parts of the country where
all of those resources haven't been
deployed yet of course the department of
education will continue to work with
them and our department of education has
also taken steps far in advance of the
last few weeks to work with states on on
anticipating and preparing for labor
shortages so we are in touch at every
level
what our position continues to be is
that
schools need to be open we are on the
side of schools being open
we believe that there are the mitigation
measures the steps and the resources to
do exactly that
go ahead
thank you jen about those mitigation uh
efforts
one way in which to reduce the spread of
covid
is through the use of masks and health
officials have
said that these cloth masks are
virtually useless you need to use they
say a kn-95
a k95 mask and as i travel i travel
around the country i see very few people
oftentimes wearing these types of masks
the k and 95 mask and my question is is
there a federal effort
to make certain that these types of
masks are available in the inner city in
rural america uh for people just getting
on an airplane because this is a better
type of mask as dr fauci has said than a
cloth mask well i would just note that
uh the cdc guidance continues to be a
well-fit mask is the best mask to be
wearing they haven't changed that
guidance as of now in terms of how these
resources uh if we talk about schools
and keeping schools open can be used the
purchase of masks certainly could be a
part of that it's up to school districts
and local school districts
to to make those decisions we also of
course work with community health
centers rural health centers local
health leaders on what they feel their
needs are and how resources from the
american rescue plan and coveted
packages in the past should be spent but
the guidance has not changed from the
cdc
but we do listen to local health leaders
on what their needs are and how the
resources that have already been
approved can be can be effectively
deployed
[Music]
that could be taken from the american
rescue plan devoted towards this federal
effort i don't think that's what i said
i think
sure well 130 billion dollars of the
rescue plan was for schools that can be
used in a range of ways uh and so some
of that money has not even been spent
yet it's it is all let's in states but
uh i think there's an allowance for that
uh but i can certainly check if there's
more specific measures i just think it's
important to note that the cdc has not
changed their guidance on masks talks
that
took place in geneva today between the
us and russia
the last time that president putin spoke
about this impasse that exists was
during his end of the year press
conference and during that end of the
year press conference
president putin said the ball is in the
u.s court on this particular issue which
is different than what you said when i
asked you that same question
in
early december
do you disagree with that contention
that the ball is in the u.s court here
well i think it's not just about me
disagreeing the facts disagree with that
there russia and president putin has
built up a troop presence of a hundred
thousand troops on the border of ukraine
they have used bellicose rhetoric it is
up to them to determine if they are
going to de-escalate if there is a
diplomatic path forward that is a path
forward that remains open but certainly
it's up to president putin to make those
choices i just want to get to everyone
so let me try to jump around seven
before i have to go go ahead thank you
again uh there's two quick questions um
i wonder a group of congressional
democrats
wrote to the white house um urging the
president to use executive power to
essentially use the defense production
act to manufacture not for habitat so
that americans could each take one test
per week um i wonder if white has white
house had any response to that and if
they think that is you know an
achievable goal something that they
would shoot for um
well we we've seen that letter the good
news is that we agree and we're already
doing most of what's in that letter so
we use the depends production act to
drive production of these tests and
we'll do so again when it can accelerate
production and delivery of these tests
we used uh deployed three billion
dollars procurement of tests we used
three billion dollars to procure tests
uh which was which became a major driver
uh in increasing expanding the market uh
four tests um and the president's plan
to procure and distribute 500 million
tests to all americans is in and of
itself providing a major stimulant
stimulus for global production of these
tests we agree that's why we've already
used the defense production act i know
they referenced the hotline there'll be
more details on that this week
our objective here is to expand access
to free public testing as is referenced
there we're already in the process of
sending 50 million rapid antigen tests
directly to federally qualified health
centers i know they reference that into
rural health clinics and we're
publishing guidance as i noted uh we'll
have more details later today on that so
the good news is that we agree with what
a lot of what they're saying and we uh
we have already taken steps to uh put in
place a number of measures
uh you mentioned
the chicago schools issue um you
mentioned that the administration has
been in talk with the mayor and the
governor has anybody from the
administration been in touch directly
with the teachers union and if not
we are in touch regularly with the
teachers union uh and and have certainly
been but i don't have any more details
go ahead thank you a couple quick
questions here i know you don't want to
weigh in on ongoing litigation before
the supreme court but not long ago in
this room the surgeon general told us
that code misinformation was a public
health threat
i'm wondering if the white house is at
all concerned uh given uh supreme court
justices sotomayor's remarks about the
omicron variant um that maybe the danger
is being overhyped and your message is
not getting out i think i just addressed
this didn't i answer this question
are you worried that there's
misinformation that is being spread so
much so that even the sitting supreme
court justice has an accurate picture of
things again i'm just not going to weigh
in on a specific legal argument made in
the court
i know you've been asked several times
about chicago you've said it here you've
said it before
you know the president clearly wants
schools to be open um there's been money
that's been allocated uh
can we expect that the president will be
more aggressive and use the bully pulpit
to tell teachers unions in chicago
to get black in the classroom i mean
this is the
third the nation's third largest school
district well again i would note the
president has been very clear as we we
have been clear we are on the side of
schools being open that is why he
advocated for funding in the american
rescue plan and we will continue to
convey that clearly because he believes
the mental health impact on kids
is could be dire and it is imperative
that kids are in the classroom more than
95 percent of schools across the country
are doing exactly that and we're hopeful
that will continue to increase
yeah quickly
in december uh you and i talked about
the uh afghan women who had been honored
here at the state department
sources are telling us right now
currently that some of these women are
being told that before they can apply
for refugee status uh they need to leave
the country and if they they do that
though you know
the odds are good that their bank
account will be seized and that process
is a two year long process
um
is there are there any additional
resources that are going to them
currently i know it's a challenging
situation and it's in flux but
is there anything more you can tell us
about trying to get this let me check on
more specific details obviously the
state department is overseeing all of
our programs and we're continuing to
work to get more people out but i will
see if there's more details on this and
i'll ask them specifically go ahead and
the way back thank you i wanted to ask
you about india u.s relationship what is
on president agenda for this year when
it comes to the world's two largest
democracies
well as you know uh back in september
the president hosted uh president moody
at the white house and their meeting was
about launching a new chapter in the
history of the u.s india relationship at
that time the two leaders laid out their
shared vision for the u.s india
relationship and will continue to work
closely this year you can expect our
governments will be moving forward on a
wide ranging set of initiatives from
cooperating to fight the pandemic
scaling up action to address climate
change working bilaterally and through
the quad expanding our cooperation in
trade and investments cyber and in new
and emerging technologies
and continuing to talk about uh and as
always we are focused on strengthening
the deep ties between our people and our
shared democratic values that underpin
the relationship but obviously we're
going to continue to build from here
quickly on china's aggressive behavior
on this border with india
does this comes into your talks with the
chinese case is the u.s sending any
message to the chinese on this
well we continue to closely monitor the
situation we continue to support
dialogue and peaceful resolution of
these border disputes we've been pretty
clear
how we view beijing's behavior in the
region around the world uh we believe it
can be destabilizing and we're concerned
by the prc's attempt to intimidate its
neighbors we'll continue to stand with
our partners on that last one go ahead
goldman sachs is saying that there's
gonna be four rate hikes this year the
federal reserve indicated maybe three if
they move a quarter of a point the
committee for federal uh responsible
federal budget says that three hikes
would add an additional 175 billion
dollars a year to a debt payment alone
so does this change the thinking of the
white house in terms of how much
spending the president wants to do as
the rate hugs start to come in well
first i always like to say monetary
policy is the purview of the federal
reserve and we respect their
independence um interest rates uh have
been kind of as you touched on there at
historically low levels during the
pandemic we always knew that as the
economy recovered and gained strength
interest rates would rise to more
historically typical levels the
president is committed as you talk about
spending to fiscal responsibility and
ensuring that our long-term investments
are fully paid for that's why he has
proposed a range of ways to pay for uh
his build back better agenda and he and
why it's fully paid for and would still
lower the cost for americans on
prescription drugs child care and many
other issues but he is somebody who is
is mindful about being fiscally
responsible and is focused on that as he
looks to his agenda moving forward
go ahead
so the president talks about the
transition away from gas
cars recently announcing the mileage
standards going up 40 miles per gallon
over the next in the next five years
he's pushed for electric cars um the
beast gets an estimated six miles to the
gallon uh the president's been office a
year is there any plans to make his car
electric i'm happy to check on that i
mean part of what we've talked about is
um making sure that um the fleet owned
by the united states government which is
very large beyond the beast the beast is
just one member um is is that we work
toward
making sure we're leading with our focus
on energy independence as well but i am
happy to check on his car otherwise
known as the beast thank you everyone
very much
yeah you talked about the importance of
students being back in the schools and
the mental health issues
and this administration has made a
really strong commitment to labor unions
in general so how can you disregard the
concerns of teacher unions who say the
classrooms are safe or who are concerned
that teachers the classrooms are i don't
think andre that's an accurate
characterization we've prioritized
teachers getting vaccinated first we
fought for the president fought for uh
an enormous amount of funding to ensure
that schools and classrooms could
and teachers
could take steps that could put in place
mitigation measures to make sure
students school
teachers and members of school
communities are safe and i think what
i'm echoing is what a number of people
in the public health community have
conveyed that those measures can make
sure that schools are safe can ensure
people attending school are safe no
parents want to send their schools their
kids to school in an unsafe environment
either
but we are in a very different place
than we were earlier this year and it's
important for people to be mindful of
the mental health impact on kids
something that of course many parents
across the country feel very strongly
about thank you everyone so much
thank you
okay
time
god
your cancer
[Music]
this morning
know it's is
children
okay
i'm
[Music]
foreign
uh
please
child order replays
replaced
you